So I want you to think about if you're an
animal.
And you live in the jungle.
I know this sounds crazy and all the sounds
you hear, all this stuff.
But you are so naive about how all the other
animals in the jungle are wired and you're
trying to survive.
How long do you think you would last in that
jungle as any animal?
How long do you think you would survive?
One day?
Six hours?
12 hours?
How long?
Not a long time.
All it takes is one evening.
And you go out there to try to do some [smack],
you're someone's prey, and you're dead.
That's exactly how it is in the world of business.
If you don't study other personalities and
how they're wired, and if you don't study
how this kingdom of entrepreneurship.
It's not animal kingdom.
I can call it the entrepreneur kingdom is
infested with all of these different personalities.
You ain't going to last a long time in business.
Last night I was having a conversation with
my five-year-old son, Tico, also Patrick Gabriel
Bet-David, and I always ask him the question,
"Daddy, what are the four most important things
that we focus on as a family?"
Love, respect, improve and lead, right?
And I say, "Hey, do we bully?"
No.
"Do we get bullied?"
And I asked him the question, "Daddy, who
loves you?"
He says, "Daddy, you love me."
And then last night he told me, "Daddy, everyone
loves me."
And I said, "Daddy, I wish everyone loved
me, and I wish everyone loved you."
Sometimes we paint this picture of life as
so perfect that our kids get surprised.
And sometimes we paint this picture of business
so friendly and nice and you're going to become
so successful and everyone wants you to win
big.
And then [smack], you face someone that's
not like that, and then you're eaten alive.
And you're saying, "Wait a minute.
This sucks.
Everyone's horrible."
No, it's just how people are wired.
And by the way, I'll cover 15 different animals
and what their personalities are and how they're
wired and how they view things and how they
decide and you can look at them as personalities
of people you're going to do business with.
You can't just say, "I am only going to deal
with people that are just like me!"
Nope.
Then you're going to do business with only
a couple of people.
Because you've got to learn how to do business
with all these different personalities.
And some of them are going to rub you the
wrong way.
So let's get right into it.
#1 is an eagle.
An eagle flies solo.
They're by themselves.
Their strength, they're strong.
They're independent.
They know how to feed themselves.
They don't need your help to feed them.
But they're not a leader of another group.
They're solo.
They're independent.
I know how to make money.
I'm good.
I don't need your help.
That's how they are.
They are generally going to be okay for themselves,
but if you decide to do business with somebody
like that, just keep in mind, they're about
themselves.
You've got to position them in the right place
for you to get the best out of them.
#2: Next is a horse.
Very simple.
Hardworking.
They're much about servanthood.
They want to serve people.
They're hardworking.
They make incredible people running operations.
They make incredible people in an environment
to make sure things get to get to work.
At times somebody needs to do the dirty work.
It could take 20 hours every day over a three-week
span.
They don't have a problem doing it.
Just make sure you treat them right, because
when they kick, it hurts a lot.
Because when they kick, you're going to feel
it.
When you get a kick from these horses like
the one you just saw right here, it hurts
a lot when that takes place.
#3: Shark and wolf.
Very similar.
Let me explain to you about, like this guy
here who just came out.
Our little friend.
Do you think you were staring in jaws?
Who do you think you are?
Go back home real quick, I'm doing a video.
See how scared these guys look?
Let me tell you something about these guys.
Here's sharks and wolves when you do business
with them.
Sharks care about one thing.
And that's money, profit, making money.
That's all it is.
This is where their mindset is at, okay?
They're willing to make money generally at
all costs.
When I say at all cost, they will go to the
line.
If the line is here, breaking the law, they're
right here is where they are.
Sharks.
Because it's all about money.
Now, sometimes wolves are dressed like sheep.
And if you don't know about it, they will
[smack] eat you alive.
Now someone says, "Well, should I never do
business with sharks and wolves?"
No, it's okay if you do business with them,
as long as your attorneys write the contract.
Not the other way around.
If they write up the contract, I'm not doing
business with them.
I had a couple of guys that wanted to do business
with me and do certain things.
I said, "Nope.
You have 66%, I'm 34, I'm not interested.
Because I'm not the one here that's all of
a sudden going to make a decision.
I don't have any interest in doing that part.
Because they're coming from here [shark/wolf].
Now, if I'm better that they're going to make
money, they will make money.
You just need to know this personality.
#4: Next, rhino.
Rhinos are the ones that will work their tails
off and put their head down and get to work.
Just sometimes on their way to wherever they're
going, where their destination is, they break
a lot of things.
So they're not the most finesse - they don't
have finesse.
It's not about finesse with them.
It's just, you want me to get over there?
I'm going to get to that destination.
I'm going to run through some trees.
I may run though a couple of people.
I may have stepped on a couple of animals
here.
But I'm going to get to that place.
So you need to know where to position a rhino
when you're doing business with them.
Don't expect them to have a lot of finesse.
#5: Next, sheep.
Unfortunately, sheep, in the world of politics,
politicians get elected because they master
how to communicate with them.
See, they're not trying to get the votes of
somebody who understands the games of politics.
This [sheep] is how they get elected.
And you need to understand as you're watching
this, this is the last thing you want to be.
Most people, they say, "I am not a sheep.
There's no way I'm a sheep.
Everyone is a sheep in something.
Let me explain.
If you never played the money game, investment,
finance, real estate, you've never bought
a home.
You don't know anything about investments.
You're a sheep in that world.
And if you're not careful about educating
yourself about money, someone's going to take
advantage of you, if you run into the wrong
person.
So everyone is a sheep in something.
You've just got to make sure you get educated
in the business that you're doing business
with and you definitely don't want to be a
sheep long term in the world of business because
somebody will devour you.
Learn how to become a better business person.
#6: Monkey.
Let me tell you about monkeys.
Here's the good thing and bad thing about
monkeys in the world of business.
They are so attractive and so entertaining
because all they want to do is have fun.
They're so much about monkeying around and
having fun and telling jokes and all this
other stuff, that they can actually convert
you into their show that they're putting up
and you don't get any business done.
That's what they do.
Monkeys.
They procrastinate a lot.
They're more worried about hey, let's go have
a beer afterwards.
Let's have fun afterwards.
Let's go to the club.
That's what monkeys are doing.
In the business, I did a lot of business with
people who had this personality.
That was their priority.
I had to know the difference and separate
myself to be focused on the business that
was growing.
Next, a sloth.
Unfortunately, you're going to recruit and
work with a lot of people who are sloths.
It's going to happen.
Lazy, nothing gets done.
Very slow.
If they give you a deadline that's the 13th,
they're not going to get it done until the
30th.
If you tell them to get something done by
1:00, tomorrow 4:00 in the afternoon, maybe.
And if you say, "I'm so sick and tired of
doing business with a sloth," either fire
them, or you adjust to them.
Because they're not changing.
That's how they are wired.
A sloth, if you have them in your environment.
Many, many of them stay like this.
A few of them change.
#8: Next, a lion.
Lion is a controversial one because a lot
of people love to say, "I'm a lion heart.
I'm a lion!
I'm a this.
I'm a that."
So many people think they're lions, but you
eventually, it takes five, 10, 15, 20 years,
sometimes to figure out who the real lion
in an environment was.
There are a lot of wannabe lions.
There's a lot of people that are loud and
make a lot of noise like lions, but lions
is here [heart].
Lion is not here [out there].
Lion is how you perform during difficult challenges,
all that other stuff.
The one that talks a lot is the great promoter,
but a lion is the one that's going to get
the job done and everyone respects them.
This is the leader.
Listen, one of my favorite quotes of all time
said by a philosopher it's if lions could
talk, we could not understand them.
Here's why.
Lions are visionaries.
They see the future.
They see what it is to run the jungle.
They see who's harmless.
They see who can harm.
They see who's playing games.
The lion looks at the whole picture of the
jungle.
Okay.
They don't just look at one part of it.
They see what's going on.
And they're good at, you know, becoming the
kings in the world of business.
You, as you're watching this, if you're either
a lion that's great, now the next goal is
to make sure you also know how to breed other
lions who take over jungles in their own business,
if you're in the business of building leaders.
#9: Next, we have snakes.
You're going to face a lot of snakes in business.
They're everywhere.
You can't run away from them.
They're going to be in business.
They're in politics.
They're in families.
They're in relationships.
They're in your apartment building you're
living in.
You have neighbors in your community.
You have people on T.V.
People that are your friends, you don't even
know, but they have snake tendencies.
And they're always maneuvering.
They always have to have something on you.
They're always.
. . you've got to be careful with them.
And by the way, for some that say I'll never
do business with a person that's a snake,
if you're doing business with a massive amount
of people, there could be a couple of people
on there.
You've just got to keep your eye ready for
them, because you're probably doing business
with them but you don't know about it.
#10: Next, cats.
Cats are very strategic, calculating.
You know because there's so much into survival
mode.
You know how nine lives that hey, let me see
what I can do to get this from here, and let
me act like I'm not interested and I'm not
hurt.
Or I don't care, but I really do.
And I don't want to act like I care about
any of this stuff.
But I'm going to get what I want, because
I know how to play this game.
That's cats.
And by the way, it's attractive, but you also
got to know who's the cat.
And the sooner you know who's the cat, the
sooner you know how to adjust to the cat tendencies
on how they are.
#11: Dogs, phenomenal.
Easy, loyal.
Great listeners.
They great as a partner.
They're great as a board that wants to take
feedback and they're very fair.
And they're able to give you feedback on everything.
They're not afraid to tell you the truth,
but they're willing to listen to you.
Encouraging.
Great, great partners and people to be in
business with.
#12:Dolphins, every company needs a dolphin.
Dolphins are extremely smart, and they're
incredible communicators.
Right?
That's what they're known for.
Those are great combinations for people in
business.
Smart and communication?
Are you kidding me?
This is like a beautiful partnership to have.
And they're non-stop.
So workers that are thinking smart and communication,
you're in a good place here.
#13: Fox - noncommittal.
They don't ever fully commit.
They're always afraid.
They always think someone's after them.
They always think someone's about to get them
because they're wired like that, they think
everybody else is wired like that.
You got to ask yourself the question, why
are foxes the way they are?
Why are they so, you know, paranoid about
everybody?
Because you got to watch - they know who they
are.
So they think everybody's like them.
But the world's not like them.
That's why they fall prey to foxes.
Because foxes are not committal, and they
come and they get what they want, and then
all of a sudden [snap], boom!
You're a prey.
Too late.
They took one of your people.
They did one over here.
They did one over there.
And you lost a couple of people.
That's foxes.
They're very good at what they do.
#14: Chicken, chickens are just afraid.
They're sensitive.
The smallest thing you say to them, they're,
"I can't believe you said this, bawk bawk."
You know.
Paul - that's a rooster.
Chicken.
I told you chicken.
That's a chicken.
It's like the simple stuff I'm trying to get
Paul to realize the different sound effects
of animals.
Eventually we're going to figure this thing
out.
Paul, what do you think?
Yes?
We'll figure this thing out here.
Okay.
So chickens are afraid.
They're sensitive.
You tell them something and they back down.
If you have somebody that works for you in
your environment.
They don't know how to make decisions.
They're always going to try to please everybody.
They just don't make good leaders.
Chickens don't.
And if you're somebody that's watching this
and you're a chicken, and if you want to go
out there and become somebody else, you may
want to start working on adjusting that, because
in the world of business, you're not going
to make it too long.
You know, just think about what meat we get
a lot.
We eat a lot of chicken.
Okay.
So you do not want to be a chicken.
You get eaten up pretty quickly.
And then last but not least, elephants.
Smart, brilliant, powerful.
But they move very slow.
Okay.
They're smart, they're powerful, they have
a lot of strength.
But they move very, very slow.
here's what elephants are.
They're going to move at their pace.
They're not going to move at your pace.
They're not going to be the most successful,
influential, all this other stuff.
They're going to do it at their pace.
But they're actually good at what they do.
So, I shared this with you for a very simple
reason.
I get a lot of people that say, I had this
business partner and it didn't work out.
Emails, I put a million and a half dollars
in this business, but it didn't work out because
the guy I teamed up with is this, this, that.
You know, I was working over here and this
is what I did and this didn't work.
Look, here's here you are.
I told you the different animals in the animal
kingdom or the jungle, and you can take this
and look at all the different personalities.
I'm just giving you 15 of them, that you're
going to do business with.
If you don't adjust based on this, and it
happens to you, it's on you.
It's not on everybody else.
You were given the information.
It's as if you're an animal, coming to our
jungle to want to live in this jungle and
somebody gave you the instruction on all the
animals.
What you decide to do from here moving forward,
it's on you.
Because you are the final decision maker on
the choice that you make.
And people who become successful eventually,
one of their biggest strengths is they know
how to read people.
They have intuition.
They have a feel.
I don't feel good about this person.
Because it's only about them.
And I have to be careful.
I'm not necessarily going to fire them, but
I need to be very, very careful.
Because this person changes very quickly from
your friend to an enemy.
You need to be careful with this person.
Right?
They're not forgiving.
They're not this.
This person man, they're such an amazing person,
I'm trying to get this person to be this person
but this person's phenomenal at this position.
Why am I trying to change them?
I need to make sure I reposition them in a
better place to get the best out of them.
That's on you to do.
So with that being said, that's the message
of the day for you on Valuetainment.
Take care everybody.
Bye bye.